[Musique]
pour la troisième année consécutive le
pôle emploi de saint pierre a ouvert ses
portes au public de plus de 50 ans
pendant une après midi autour d'ateliers
sur l'outil informatique et la
différence de cette troisième édition
c'est commencer cet apprentissage de
manière proactive trois mois avant en a
fait un diagnostic on établit des
niveaux le niveau de connaissance de
matériel informatique l'existence ou pas
dead à la maison et on a pu construire
un parcours personnalisé pour développer
ses compétences pour l'accès à ces
informations via le digital donc ce plan
seniors iii il a commencé il ya trois
mois et son poids d'apothéose c'est
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui en un
seul clic
ils peuvent avoir accès à ses
informations à ses services et à ses
droits
l'occasion de réunir plusieurs
partenaires afin d'apporter des réponses
aux seniors de les redynamiser dans leur
recherche d'emploi ainsi que de
faciliter l'accès à leurs droits
c'est tout à fait normalement que le
conseil départemental qui accompagnent
ces publics puissent mener en
partenariat avec pôle emploi la cave la
sécurité sociale une démarche vraiment
transversale pour accompagner nos
publics dans la recherche en pas mais
aussi dans la recherche de leurs droits
et aussi pour les accompagner tout
simplement dans leurs démarches de mise
en place de leur retraite
seniors en un seul clic un partenariat
de lutte contre la fracture numérique
chez les seniors qui a encore cette
année remporté un franc succès
[Musique]